[Music]
do you keep in touch with the kids to a
degree
michael fox is 3 000 miles away justine
is busy
raising two children of her own as his
teeny others i try to see michael when
i'm on the east coast we usually try and
do a breakfast or a lunch together
once a tv dad always a dad michael girl
spent seven seasons as the former hippie
turned father of everyone's favorite
young republican alex p keaton and his
sisters the 60s are over dad thanks for
the tip
the sitcom that debuted in 1982 was a
hit right from the start in the
beginning that first year did you guys
have any idea no well how do i look
middle-aged
all i knew is on the pilot i made more
money that i never made in one play in
my life
i was making a lot of money on that
pilot you know
even though i was still living in my car
i was
i made a lot of money so that was
exciting alone now the only reason we
ended kevin was the fact that we had a
built-in time bomb which was the
the the ages of the children we've got
alex p keaton we've taken him through
high school college graduate school he
wants to conquer the world he's still
living at home with mommy and daddy it
makes no sense
i don't believe this how could i let
this happen your kids became iconic
michael j fox he became a star oh
absolutely i remember walking into the
mail room and finding just these gobs of
mail from pre-teens going
this is our guy so that was before back
to the future so you just saw you said
oh
oh this is a phenomenon what if they say
get out of here kid you got no future we
were all aware
that this was a big deal but michael was
the same humble
wonderful guy
who and he will tell you this knew
from the outset that family ties had
made all of this possible
and so didn't immediately pull the plug
and say i'm out of here
right i'm out of here or i want
something very special
i assume his salary went up a bit
people used to say to me how do you feel
mike fox is this big star i mean do you
you feel terrible about that i said
i went to school with meryl streep i
said so there was meryl streep before
there was michael fox
michael turns 75 on tuesday he shares a
birthday with his tv wife meredith
baxter they're still close friends and
get this 33 years after the show wrapped
michael still has all his mementos from
the set
the pilot script of family ties
february 1982 the pilot script
uh and uh and then
i didn't save a lot the final episode
1989. i want to show you something
of course e.t was everywhere
including on your set oh my god the
bearded michael we have
the world at our doorstep to a certain
extent
half half the half the sets that were
turned on last night were watching us in
the sensory creates a kind of
responsibility fascinating who's that
young fellow
[Laughter]
there was all that dark hair i got the
job alex great is there ever a chance
that you would do a reunion with the
group i don't think a reunion is in the
cards okay because i think um i don't
think there's the interest from the
writers and i can't imagine working with
another group of writers i don't know
that i want people looking at family
ties going
he hasn't really aged that well has he
[Music]